Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new black panther 2 video a couple first looks
for the movie drop so we'll break it all down
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs obviously
connections to everything that's happening
in marvel phase four marvel phase five with
all the incursions the secret wars lead up just
love the way that they're getting us hyped up to
watch the multiverse burn to the ground slowly
as they form their version of battle world and
like the mcu version of secret wars but if
you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're going to
get a black panther 2 trailer really soon too
probably around the time thor love and thunder
hits theaters so big reminder black panther
2 is coming this year it's just taking the
november slot and they have the two different
black panther two spin-off disney plus series
there's one that's just gonna take place in
wakanda they haven't said specifically what
it's about or who the main characters are going
to be but then there's a separate one just about
okoye like okoye has her own disney plus spin-off
we probably won't see those till like 2024 but you
may have seen your fees first looks for a couple
of the biggest characters in the film have dropped
like there's footage of them at mit shuri nikoi's
looks during the film and namor and it boss the
panther goddess thanks to all the thor love and
thunder first looks and trailer videos this we're
gonna meet the goddess of wakanda the goddess that
most of the people in wakanda worship particularly
black panther he has a special agreement with her
where he gets some of his powers from not
all of his powers but some of his powers
she comes from the same pantheon of egyptian gods
that konju comes from she's actually conscious
sister that's right gods can have biological
children so that's how thor and hela exist i don't
know how much of a role she plays during actual
black panther 2 i believe that they're using her
mostly during thor love and thunder just because
of everything that's happening with gore the god
but you're going around killing all the gods let's
see who you are i take off your disguise and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
but no i don't think they're gonna let gore kill
off boss the panther goddess during that movie
i've already done a bunch of thor love and thunder
videos about what's going on with her character in
the mcu so i won't talk too much about her in
this video i'll put links in the description
below for those videos that i've already done
a lot of people also wondering what's going on
with them passing the mantle of black panther
like who will be the next black panther because
kevin feige like literally came out and said
we are not going to recast t'challa in the mcu
and it's for that reason that we will not recast
the character there have been so many rumors about
that so i'll address that later in the video too
because i think some of the more recent rumors are
more correct than some of the previous ones in
one of the new scenes that we've gotten a look
at is in honor of chadwick boseman's memory like
there's a big easter egg honoring his memory so if
you look here this is just the normal throne room
from the black panther movie in avengers infinity
war but what you might notice is that there's a
brand new inscription on the pillars here that
was not in the black panther movie or avengers
infinity war the inscription here is written in
their main wakandan language they actually have
multiple dialects that they speak around the
nation of wakanda but wakandan is kind of like
their common language that they all speak on
top of all the dialects and in their language the
inscription reads rest in power king t'challa our
hero it has been an honor wakanda forever so it's
them saying it's been an honor to chadwick boseman
in real life but also within the context of the
movie they're paying honor to his passing even
though ryan coogler and kevin feige said that they
would honor chadwick boseman and t'challa's memory
during the movie they didn't say exactly what they
would be doing to address what happened to the
character within the mcu but it looks like in this
brand new footage of them fighting at mit you see
shuri getting ready to fight what seems like the
forces of atlantis namor maybe that have come to
mit to try and find out what's going on with riri
williams new technology now she's going to be iron
heart in the mcu it sounds like they just started
filming the iron heart series but that won't
drop till next year she's not meant to be like a
replacement for iron man or anything like that she
has her whole own separate identity called iron
heart it's completely different set of armor iron
man doesn't give that to her she's meant to be
another dumpster diver in the vein of spider-man
and iron man where she winds up cobbling together
her own version of an armor suit that's just way
more advanced than what you see from people like
justin hammer and the like in the comics she was
an mit undergrad in their engineering program
and getting to the iron man of it all because
she kind of flows from the iron man mythology
in the comics the whole connection between her
armor and iron man their characters you remember
during the first iron man movie at the beginning
when he's getting that award in vegas they read a
little of his history up to the point when he's a
child when he goes through school how he created
all these advanced engineering designs when he was
just a little kid then eventually graduated from
mit when he was only 16 years old big deep cut
reference if you remember that movie real genius
from the 80s it's a cool val kilmer 80s movie
imagine tony stark is a character during that and
because of when that movie was made robert downey
jr could have actually shown up during that just
a bunch of really smart kids in an engineering
program getting to all kinds of trouble the funny
connection to what just happened to spider-man no
way home is that almost the entire plot hinged on
spider-man trying to get himself and all of his
friends into mit so for a hot second he almost
went to school with riri williams but i think
we're all expecting them to swerve on that plot
keep him in the new york city area and either
go to empire state like he did during the tope
maguire spiderman era or it'll be some other big
twist i saw a couple rumors that the main villain
of her cirrus might wind up actually being obadiah
stane's son zeke stane in the comics he's a big
iron man villain too zeke stane is if you remember
they actually name-dropped obara stane during the
hawkeye series and i think that was meant to be
a bit of a teaser for something that they'll
pay off later on like obadiah stane's legacy
inside the mcu will come to bear during hawkeye
episode one you find out that the school that kate
bishop has been attending that she eventually
probably winds up getting kicked out of
obadiah stan's name is on one of the buildings
like he contributed the funds to build one of
the buildings assuming that he either went there
at one point in history or his son went there too
his son winds up being a little bit like obadiah
staying a little bit like justin hammer trying
to get his hands on iron man's technology but rui
williams is sort of like a left turn when it comes
to iron man technology in the mcu the new report
is that she's created some kind of new technology
that's threatened the atlanteans in namor and
that's what's driven them off the rails and
why they're so pissed off during the movie in the
way they're portraying atlantis during the movie
is it's a little bit like wakanda like this hidden
city with a bunch of advanced technology with this
ancient race that's been untouched by time but as
opposed to wakanda something that riya williams
has done or some new technology that they've
created threatens the city like the rest of the
world is descending on it the same way that they
wanted to get their hands on all the technology in
wakanda and all the vibranium so they're trying
to provide this parallel between what's going
on with namor's character and what's going on
with black panther like they're both going to
be kings of their people black panther already
became king of his people but i believe the idea
is that namor's parents wind up getting killed
during the film and it's a very captain america
civil war black panther type of story like very
similar things will happen in their story arcs
where black panther only became king because his
father had been murdered and the same is true of
neymar in the mcu so this sort of drives some
of the beef that's happening between namor and
black panther's people during the film but one
of the other first looks at okoye here you can
see she and shuri have come to mit to try and
scope out what's going on with riri williams
and you see them wearing a couple different
costumes during the film and it seems like
they've come to scope out what's actually going
on with all these claims that namor has made
you notice she's wearing regular plain clothes as
opposed to the first movie when she was wearing
that formal dress the nightclub she's also not
wearing a wig you also notice she's wearing red
again like red is her trademark color and she's
not bothering to hide any of her tribal tattoos
shuri has also changed her hairstyle she's wearing
a slightly different purple track suit both of
their outfits look very retro yet futuristic at
the same time which is kind of trademark wakanda
and the really cool thing they only barely got
into during the first movie is that vibranium
isn't just using all their metal weaponry and
technology like their computers they also use
vibranium in almost every single major physical
type of object vibranium is technically even in
their food supply because of the way the mineral
from the great mound the vibranium meteorite has
leached into the soil of wakanda for thousands of
years the special heart-shaped herb even gained
its special properties because it was created when
the vibranium mixed into the soil with the natural
plant life creating this new alien kind of flower
so black panther literally eats vibranium kind of
in order to get some of his powers and enter
the alternate dimension of the ancestral plane
which they obviously name-dropped during moon
night when it comes to them passing the mantle of
black panther during the film like who will be the
next black panther in the mcu there were a lot of
rumors early on that mbaku was actually going to
take leadership of wakanda even though technically
shuri would have a stronger claim to the throne
because it was her older brother who was the
previous king but there was a new rumor a while
ago that you may have heard about that they're
going to introduce the idea that black panther
had a son with nokia they just didn't reveal
till present day and when that son was old enough
he would take up the mantle of black panther so
technically black panther has a surprise child
who is the next black panther eventually i don't
know if that's true but that actually feels like
a direction that they would go with because that
would be kind of like sidestepping the issue like
who's gonna be the next black panther well we're
gonna win that game by not playing that game so
let me know in the comments who do you think is
actually going to be the next black panther and do
you think they're just going to hold off actually
naming the next black panther until we get to like
black panther 3 or some other huge crossover movie
it feels like they would save that for a black
panther sequel though the other big new thing that
we gotta look at is it seems like the atlanteans
will be worshiping the jaguar god and namor for
instance will have a similar relationship
with that got a similar agreement that black
panther has with boss the panther goddess now this
particular part with the jaguar god is specific to
black panther 2. i don't know if they get into
this during thor love and thunder we know we'll
see the panther goddess and thor 11 thunder but
if we're trying to think about how they'll explain
t'challa passing away during the film they might
just say that namor winds up assassinating him and
him forming a contract with the jaguar god gaining
special powers would enable him to do something
like that it just depends on how they explain
name wars powers inside the mcu so post all your
theories about that in the comments below too but
everyone click here for my brand new thor love and
thunder trailer and easter eggs and click here for
my stranger things season 4 volume 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!